[ Theme music plays ]
-From Studio 6B
in Rockefeller Center,
in the heart of New York City,
it's "The Tonight Show
Starring Jimmy Fallon."
-♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey ♪
-Tonight, join Jimmy and
his guest, Caleb McLaughlin,
and featuring
the legendary Roots crew.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Fallon five!
-And now here he is --
Jimmy Fallon!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey ♪
♪ Hey, hey, hey, hey-ey ♪
-Wow. Thank you very, very much!
Thank you!
Thank you, every--
Thank you, everybody.
Thank you so much
for being here.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Chuckles ]
Please, we only have
five minutes.
[ Laughter ]
I hope everyone's enjoying
the Olympics.
Since we only have
five minutes tonight,
we thought
we'd try something fun
and see if we can do
a lo-fi mini version
of an entire
"Tonight Show" episode.
it's gonna be quick, so let's
get right into it, right here.
Well, guys, there have been
so many amazing moments
during the Olympics,
so many highs and lows.
And a lot of people have been
making memes of these moments,
so we made a few of our own.
I'll show you
what I'm talking about.
First up, take a look
at this photo
of figure skater Adam Rippon.
This meme is called...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Everything's cool!
I'm good!"
Next is a photo
of three women's curlers.
[ Light laughter ]
Their meme is...
It's like...
[ Laughter and applause ]
"People do that?"
And finally, here's a photo
of snowboarder Shaun White.
His meme says...
"Oh, yeah! Yo!"
We have a great show
for you tonight.
Let's keep it moving, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you, guys.
[ Chuckles ]
[ Laughter ]
My -- Thank you, guys.
My guest tonight
is one of the stars
of the popular Netflix series
"Stranger Things."
Please welcome Caleb McLaughlin,
everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Nice to see you, Caleb!
-Nice to see you, too!
Welcome...
[ Applause ]
Welcome to the show.
Thank you for being here.
[ Laughter ]
-No problem, no problem.
Thank you for having me.
-No problem.
Yeah, I feel
like I'm a little short
or something.
Is that something
you can do for me?
-[ Chuckles ]
-can you get me up here?
Oh.
-There it is.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Thank you buddy.
-No problem, no problem.
-Good to see you.
Congrats on all the success.
-Thank you.
-I love you
on "Stranger Things."
Last time I saw you was
at the Knicks game.
-Yes.
-You were on the Jumbotron.
-Oh, yes.
-And the place went bonkers.
And I was like,
"Look at this kid, man."
-I know!
-But I heard that you wanted
to play for the NBA.
Is that true?
-Yes, I've always
wanted to play.
Like, right now, I low-key still
want to play in the NBA, yeah.
-Well, you got really close.
-Yeah, I know I'm --
this weekend, I was
at the NBA All-Star game,
and I played
in the celebrity game, so...
- How cool is that?
-I know, that was so awesome.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, let's
talk "Stranger Things."
It's streaming now on Netflix.
Congratulations.
The whole cast
scores this season.
-Thank you.
-For those who haven't been --
binge-watched it yet,
can you set it up at all?
-Who's -- Well,
like, Season One...
-At the end, we saw the kid
was just barfing up slugs.
-Yep, yep,
so it's, like, aftermath.
After that, like,
see what's going on with him,
and then there's newcomers.
We go more into the story line
of each character.
You go into my family
a lot more.
Now it's not, "Where's
the black kid's parents?"
It's like, "Oh, look,
it's in his family."
[ Laughter ]
The Sinclairs, you know?
[ Laughter and applause ]
So you get to see more of that.
-Good for you.
-Yeah.
Some big stuff, yeah.
-I'm happy we get to see that.
Yeah. I'd like
to show a clip here.
Here's a scene from Season Two
of "Stranger Things."
Check this out.
Now, Caleb, you're gonna have to
help me with this,
if you don't mind.
-All right.
-Okay.
-Oh, yeah, it's kind of...
[ Laughter ]
Okay, make sure
you look at the Dumpster.
-Okay, good.
-Keep your eye on the Dumpster.
Oh, whoa.
Ooh.
[ Audience oohs ]
Well, well, well.
-There you go.
-Oh, my gosh,
that's a great clip.
That was a fantastic clip.
It looks great!
Caleb, thank you so much
for stopping by!
-Thank you!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Be sure to check out
"Stranger Things" Season Two,
streaming now on Netflix.
My thanks to Caleb McLaughlin,
The Roots,
and to you for tuning in.
We are out of time.
Thank you for watching, and
I hope to see you tomorrow.
Bye-bye everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪